[Musica]
Non vedo l'ora che sia domani per
sposarci
[Musica]
compleanno vostra Grazia Regina di cuori
È ora di tagliargli la testa cartoni
animati nella vita reale è successo
qualcosa nel mondo dei cartoni animati e
per scoprire cos'è e salvarli dobiamo
entrare nel mondo dei cartoni nella vita
reale ma cominciamo subito con il primo
cartone Bretto stiamo per essere
teletrasportati nel primo mondo ma cosa
sta
[Musica]
succedendo Ma dove siamo Qual è il
nostro primo cartone animato nella vita
reale guardiamoci intorno magari
scopriamo qualcosa Oh no mi devo
sbrigare è tardi Devo andare ma che ci
fate ancora qui è tardi lei ci aspetta
aspetta chi Chi è tardi per cosa presto
seguiamolo
[Musica]
presto presto è tardi ci aspetta Fermati
fermo Fermati aspetta Dove stai andando
Ehi aspetta aspetta aspetta Ma tu chi
sei ma io sono il Bianconiglio non mi
riconosci Alice Alice Io sono Anita non
al ho capito siamo in al nel Paese delle
Meraviglie E io chi sono Non lo so non
ti ho mai visto in questo regno e se tu
sei Alice Io sono la meraviglia No ma
che dici ma insomma che cosa dobbiamo
fare per salvare questo cartone dovete
prendere le rose e dovete fare in fretta
perché è tardi non rimane molto tempo e
se non le prendete Tutte
lei devo scappare devo scappare
tardi
Ma sbaglio era un po' strano quel
coniglio Sì infatti ma presto dobbiamo
trovare tutte le rose altrimenti
arriverà non ho capito chi è scappato
sbrighiamoci andiamo a cercare tutte le
rose subito Sì andiamo
Oh Ma che bellissimo fiore che ho
trovato lo regalerò ad Anita Anita Anita
vieni vieni vieni che ti devo far vedere
una cosa Hai trovato qualcosa Eh beh sì
eh È un regalo per te hai trovato una
delle Rose delle Challenge Bravissimo Oh
era una rosa delle Challenge non me nero
nemmeno accorto eh Ehi Alice Hai sentito
anche tu sì Ehi c'è qualcuno che sta
parlando la voce di qualcuno da dietro
l'albero proviene da laggiù Alice sei
tornata nel paese delle meraviglie Che
bello unaltra Rosa Prendimi Prendimi
Prendila netto non riesco Ahia così mi
fai male però Pian non riesco a
prenderla Ma perché questa rosa parla
essere più del
[Musica]
perfetto abbiamo due rose
adesso la senti anche tu questa musica
Sì sì viene proprio da lì andiamo a
vedere andiamo
andiamo buon compleanno a me a te un
buon compleanno a te Auguri è il nostro
non compleanno che Gi Oggi il mio
compleanno Auguri ah dammi un abbraccio
poggiamo le tazze per che arriva il
treno del tè un buon compleanno a me a
te guarda chi c'è Ah il nostro amico
topino cosa dice io non posso
festeggiare oggi è il mio vero
compleanno è il tuo compleanno oh No beh
Vorrà dire che festeggerai domani ma noi
Festeggiamo oggi il nostro non
compleanno e anche voi se oggi è il
vostro non compleanno mettete mi piace
al video un buon compleanno a me un buon
compleanno Evviva che bella festa Tutti
insieme Siamo
[Musica]
tantissimi fermo momento
te Alice sei tornata ci mancavi tanto
Oggi è il giorno del mio Nuo compleanno
e anche del suo è il vostro No non è il
nostro compleanno Auguri buon compleanno
a voi A voii
lì no lì occupato Non vedi che c'è gente
Ah ok Scusa sto scherzando Siediti tu an
No tu tu chi sei tu io sono le
meraviglie piacere cellaio matto ceniti
lì ceniti lì Alice sei cambiata ti devo
fare un bel cappello Vediamo le misure
Oh Vabbè ci pensiamo dopo prendete un tè
un buon compleanno a voi un buon
compleanno a te Oh prendi questo tu
auguri Buono
compleanno Lo sai che mi piace tanto
questa festa sto già
mangiando Grazie per questo tè ma noi in
realtà siamo qua per trovare tutte le
rose come ci ha detto il Bianconiglio
prima che il tempo scada siete di fretta
sì non si può essere di fretta per il
giorno del non compleanno eh bisogna
bere il tè Anzi te ne metto un po' è
finito il tè Oh come facciamo adesso ne
facciamo dell'altro buono complean stop
stop una domanda una domanda una domanda
da da quando siamo arrivati che devo
fare questa domanda ma questi si
potevano mangiare sono commestibili Ma
certo anche le tazze sono
commestibili Ah allora ok Un buono
compleanno a voi a voi ma quindi queste
rose per che cosa servono Beh il
Bianconiglio ci ha detto di recuperare
subito le rose altrimenti arriverà e non
ci ha detto chi
arriverà è finita l'ora del tè È tardi È
tardi fin andate via via andate
via
informazion No non andatevene
Anita ma adesso cosa facciamo che cosa
ho detto di sbagliato Ho detto solo
quello che ci aveva detto il
Bianconiglio cioè che arriverà ma non so
chi perché si sono spaventati non
capisco Ma smettila di mangiare dobbiamo
trovare le altre Rose Sbrigati Hai
ragione andiamo presto guarda ci sono
delle Rose lì è vero Vai a prenderle tu
quelle rose Io invece vado a controllare
di qua magari ne troverò delle altre Sì
così facciamo prima
ok che bello ho trovato ben due rose e
queste non parlano
nemmeno bellissime chissà quante altre
ce ne mancano ora è meglio che vado
subito a raggiungere Vitale casomai si
caccia nei guai
quello
Dove saranno queste rose io non le vedo
[Musica]
qui Vitale da
Quest Chi è che ha parlato dove qua da
questa parte Ah di qua da questa parte
non ho capito di qua Bravo Sì da questa
parte Vitale da questa
parte Ehi ma tu chi sei io sono Lo
Stregatto Vitale che sei ancora qui devi
andare Devi trovare le rose per scappare
se le rose non troverai la testa
perderai che cosa la testa no no no no
io le voglio trovare le rose perché tu
sai per caso dove sono certo che so
dov'è la Rosa la Rosa può essere rossa
gialla oppure Rosa ma c'è una rosa
speciale simile al blu sta proprio
laggiù una rosa speciale
Anita sarà felicissima di scoprire che
ho trovato la rosa speciale
Sì quindi devo andare da quella parte lì
dove ci sono quei rovi tranquillo Vitale
ti accompagno io in questa avventura e
ti proteggerò se hai paura Forse sì o
forse no andiamo stragatto ho una
domanda da farti Dimmi vit da quando
siamo arrivati qui questo paese un po'
particolare
strano tutti quanti parlano di lei se la
incontrerai devi scappare da lei ma chi
è lei non ti preoccupare Vitale sai qui
la gente è un po' matta
e viene governata da una persona molto
simpatica forse se la rosa troverai
presto la incontrerai oppure
no continuiamo Eh ok molto rassicurante
la gente è un po' matta Mh Strano non
l'avrei mai detto
guardandoti Uffa però stragatto Ma
quanto manca ma Vitale siamo arrivati
Siamo arrivati è quella Certo Quella è
la doa speciale quindi la posso prendere
Prendila oppure no ti succederà qualcosa
oppure no arriverà qualcuno oppure no Ma
quindi che devo fare la devo prendere o
non la devo prendere arriverà qualcuno
non arriverà nessuno Non lo so La scelta
è tua Prego Ok la prendo farò felice
Anita Ahia questi rovi pungono
forse l'ho quasi
presa l'ho preso davvero l'ho
fregato vostra Grazia Regina di cuori
hanno preso le sue
rose hanno preso le mie rose Sì G hanno
preso anche quella nera speciale cosa
hanno fatto hanno preso la rosa
nera dobbiamo subito andare a tagliargli
la testa Eccola stragatto lo Stregatto
dove sei Stregatto Vele vitele Guarda ho
trovato quattro rose rosse belle che
belle anite Anch'io ho trovato una rosa
Che strano ma questa non è una rosa
rossa Eh no Praticamente lo Stregatto mi
ha detto che è una rosa particolare
speciale sembra la rosa di una persona
cattiva non ci avevo pensato
però chi chi è quella oh oh non sembra
niente di buono hanno rubato le mie rose
rosse e anche la mia rosa nera speciale
tagliategli la
testa
scappiamo
vogliono tagliarci la testa SC fa Ah
dove pensate di
andare dove pensate di andare Seguitemi
so io dove andare No tu rimani qua
dobbiamo festeggiare il non compleanno
Certo Ci sono un sacco di concetti e c'è
anche il tortino Sì vieni con noi ok
Avete aspeto presto Hai recuperato tutte
le rose ora possiamo salvare il cartone
e adesso Ecco il premio Grazie a questo
potete
teletrasportarti perché appena lo tocchi
ti ti teletrasporti immediatamente
nell'altro
cartone in che cartone animato sono
finita Oh no Vitale è rimasto in Alice
nel paese delle meraviglie Almeno sono
riuscita a prendere uno dei miei libri
in tutto dobbiamo recuperare tre copie
del libro A proposito Voi ce l'avete la
città stregata è ora disponibile in
libreria e su Amazon ma ora cerchiamo di
capire in quale cartone animate sono e
voi lasciate un mi piace per aiutarmi
cliccate mi piace qua sotto vediamo che
cosa c'è in questa stanza
Ah c'è un oggetto molto interessante
qua Che
cos'è È
bellissima
Ah mi sono Punta
Inizio ad avere un po' di
[Musica]
sonno
finalmente la mia maledizione si è
compiuta Principessa Aurora ora dormirai
finché non riceverai il bacio del vero
amore e visto che al giorno d'oggi è
proprio di difficile trovare il vero
amore dormirai per
[Musica]
sempre Sì rimani qua con noi è il tuo
non compleanno giusto Esatto buon non
compleanno Aug
Grazie
compleanno
Auguri Grazie compleanno Grazie grazie
Posso avere anch'io un po' di tè No
basta no l'ora del tè è finit ma il mio
non un compleanno è il tuo
compleanno compleanno a te a te Basta
Cos'è questo baccano devo tagliare la
testa anche a voi tenete il mio
Prigioniero è ora di tagliargli la testa
Ok ragazzi Ok ok Va bene allora siete
stati molto gentili Mi avete offerto
però adesso basta eh Adesso stiamo
andando un po' un po' oltre basta
parlare Sta arrivando la Regina vli la
testa anche a noi e lo scherzo è bello
finché dura poco dai Adesso lasciatemi
Stai zitto Sta arrivando la
regina no
prepar E adesso il mio momento preferito
il taglio della
testa Aspettate aspettate chi osa
disturbare il taglio della testa aspetti
aspetti mia regina Ecco le sue Rose le
mie rose aspetta
manca quella nera io non ce l'avevo non
ce l'aveva Anita non ce l'aveva Io non
lo so ce Io ce l'ho io Lasciatemi stare
È qui La rosa nera è questa che vuoi sì
proprio questa e ora sparisci Oh bene
bene Ho salvato il cartone Allora non mi
resta che trovare Anita adesso e
scappare Seguimi Vitale è
tardi tieni Vitale si è Gi
teletrasportata portarti nel prossimo
cartone Ah ok però spero solo che si
ritroveranno nello stesso
cartone Ehi ma dove sono finito
Anita dove sei Se ci sei Vieni a
liberarmi Oh no sento dei passi sta
arrivando
qualcuno
ah Ah è una
bestia
Ah chi sei Che cosa vuoi oh mia Bell Non
vedo l'ora che sia domani per
sposarci Sei un fiore sei così bella Io
ti adoro il mio cuore appartiene a te
Belle cosa sposarci Ma io non mi voglio
sposare con una bestia e credo che hai
sbagliato persona Io sono Vitale non
Bell Ma che dici Tu sei Bell La mia
amatissima belle e domani Noi ci
sposeremo finalmente ci sposeremo No no
io non sposo proprio nessuno non mi
voglio sposare con te beh vedi tu sei in
questa prigione Perché non puoi
scegliere sono io la bestia che sceglie
di sposarsi e ho scelto te perché sei
proprio carina carina carina e quindi
preparati e adesso vado a prendere le
fedi nuziali per domani E tu fatti bella
Mi
raccomando aiuto Come faccio ad uscirne
da questa situazione Adesso però ho
capito in che cartone sono sono nel
cartone della Bella e la
Bestia No io non mi voglio sposare con
quella bestia pelosissima Tra l'altro
no eh eh Che cosa sta succedendo Ehi tu
chi sei Cosa ci fai qua dov'è la vera
belle la storia è tutta sbagliata ma chi
siete voi una tazzina di espresso e una
candela un candelabro con le candele
sciolte Ma quale candelabro con le
candele sciolte Io sono Lumiere il
servitore del padrone bestia Ecco
espresso Al massimo porto il tè e
comunque sono Chicco Ah ciao lumier ciao
Chicco Scusatemi non vi avevo
riconosciuti
eh siete qui per aiutarmi
aiutarti tu devi aiutare noi dobbiamo
trovare la vera belle così il padrone si
innamora di lei e noi potremmo tornare
umani Eh ma io vorrei aiutarti ma come
faccio da qua dentro riuscite a
liberarmi voi sì tranquillo adesso ti
liberiamo oh oh Davvero grazie Sì ma
come non abbiamo le mani Ho un'idea ci
penso io infatti un po' più in
[Musica]
là adesso Grazie grazie per avermi
liberato
manoo sbrighiamoci la bestia sta
arrivando andiamo io rimango qua così
distraggo il padrone che non si accorge
che Vitale non c'è più Ok Noi andiamo a
cercare belle credo di sapere dov'è
andiamo ti seguo Ciao A dopo
grazie Oh no siamo arrivati troppo tardi
Oh no Aurora La maledizione di si è
avverata sapevamo che un giorno si
sarebbe avverata e siamo arrivati troppo
tardi
aspetta il bacio del vero amore farà
svanire l'incantesimo Ho un'idea il
principe Filippo sta cercando una moglie
e lei è una
principessa una principessa siamo sicuri
che non sia un orco Vabbè e quindi
dovremmo farlo venire qui e fargli dare
il bacio del vero amore Solo così
riusciremo a salvare Aurora volevi dire
la bella principessa che è
russa Sì dai spieghiamoci prima che non
ci sia tempo Andi
Sì preparati perché sono un avversario
molto temibile n mio regno sono il
principe D'altronde vieni qua a
fondo ti sconfiggerò ah ah mi stai
accecando aha non ho mai visto nessuno
combattere bene come te Ah sei veramente
[Musica]
temibile va bene Stavolta hai vinto tu
ma Voglio la
rivincita odio il
teletrasporto Eccolo è lì è proprio vero
se fossi una principessa mi innamorerei
di me stesso Ah quanto sono bello Ah
quanto sono
forte principe già sento la folla che mi
acclama principe e applaude e io li
guardo E sorrido principe come un vero e
grande
principe ci penso io cara
PR Ah siete qua bene che c'è Salve
principe Filippo sappiamo che lei sta
cercando moglie Eh sì sì sì certo e
quindi Beh Avrei una proposta da farle
e come volete farmi sposare con
lui Scusate un
[Applauso]
attimo Mi spiace ma non mi interessa
Andate via adesso
schifo noi abbiamo una proposta per te
ov vero la principessa
Aurora Principessa Aurora Sì grazie al
matrimonio con una principessa
finalmente potrò diventare re aspettate
ma almeno è carina carina È uno schianto
bello Allora va bene mi fido andiamo Non
sto più nella pelle Portatemi da
[Musica]
lei una bellezza perfetta coronava la
sua giovinezza un temperamento costante
la rendeva Adorabile il suo buon cuore
tanto generoso Ciao belle Ciao G come
stai Bene e tu Bene sono solo un po'
solo Ti va di essere mia moglie no
Gaston Ne abbiamo già parlato Non voglio
essere tua moglie ma invece sì sono
bello Son muscoloso sono potente A me
non piacciono i tipi come te Cioè non
piacciono quelli forti e belli come me
no Sei stupida e arrogante ma di questo
ne parleremo più tardi invece cosa sta
facendo una bella giovincella sola
soletta stavo leggendo un libro un libro
Scusa
ma questo libro non ha neanche le figure
ma una donna della tua età non potrebbe
leggere libri e invece sì ma come fai a
leggerli se non ci sono nemmeno le
immagini perché non sono stupida come te
ah B sei proprio testarda Ma quando
sarai la mia mogliettina saremo felici e
contenti ecco quella là è belle ma
quella col bastone Ma che è quella col
bastone lei quella con l'abito azzurro B
Folco Scusami non avevo capito dobbiamo
fare in modo di parlare con belle ma
come facciamo c'è quello lì quello lì
come si chiama Ah Gastone Gastone Ma chi
Quello col bastone Vabbè non fare il
burlone Allora dobbiamo distrarre Gaston
per parlare con lei io un'idea ce l'ho
grande vieni qua Ok ti seguo allora un
po' di trucco qua Ah sono un vero
artista Allora adesso Sì S si indossa
questo ah perfetto Oh ci siamo perfetta
Fatti vedere Ah no rimani così vai ora
vai vai non c'è più tempo vai Io aspetto
qua di qua Sì di là Speriamo vada tutto
bene
Guarda B non lo vedi un futuro insieme
Molto luminoso No ciao Gaston Io sono la
principessa più bella del regno lei sarà
pure Bell Ma io sono ancora più
bell Non vedo l'ora di vedere quanto sei
bella principessa vediamo un po' Chi si
nasconde sotto questa bella parrucca
bionda 3 2 1
ah
Cè non ti piaccio
Gaston Oh ti è spaventato Gaston lo
sapevo che avrebbe
[Risate]
funzionato Grazie non lo sopportavo più
chi sei tu Lui è un infiltrato della
nostra fiaba dobbiamo aiutarlo a
arrivare a casa così possiamo salvare la
nostra storia B ci devi aiutare tu ti
fidi di noi questo è il tuo
[Musica]
destino
Va bene allora vi
[Musica]
Seguirò Eccoci qui guarda questa è la
tua principessa la più bella del reale
Ma come Mi avete portato davanti a una
principessa che dorme e non si degna
neanche di svegliarsi di fronte al mio
cospetto basta me ne vado No no no no
aspetta aspetta ci siamo dimenticati un
piccolo dettaglio ben vedi questa bella
ragazza è stata colpita da una
maledizione da Manica e quindi non si
può svegliare finché non avrà il bacio
del vero amore No no una maledizione No
ma che è contagioso io ho paura di
queste cose eh no no non è contagioso
Anzi Immagina principe Filippo ha
salvato la principessa Aurora guarda
come OM metterebbe la tua gloria vedo un
futuro molto luminoso per te Sarò un re
fantastico all principe Filippo principe
filipo Ok ok va bene Ci sto Ah quanto è
bella
è uno scherzo vero Io non posso baciare
una che russa è uno scherzo Sì lo so
questo è un altro piccolo problemino
però Immagina i titoli principe Filippo
salva la principessa Aurora io avrò il
regno più bello del mondo e sarò re va
bene la bacio anche se Rossa Filippo
Filippo principe
Filippo
ah tu chi sei Non sei il mio fidanzato
ma come vi permettete non posso baciare
una principessa che si rifiuta di
baciarmi
E ora come facciamo Sii ri addormentata
Non lo
so checchio come hai potuto far scappare
La mia spasa ma padrone aspetti lei non
è la vera bella io stavo solamente
cercando di salvare la storia la Vera
bella la tua vera sposa sta arrivando
la vera Bell Cosa significa la vera Bell
Dov'è la mia sposa padrone la vera Bell
è gua è lei non io sono io la Vera bella
e tu sei bestia come nel libro che stavo
leggendo
bella sei tu ti stavo aspettando Anch'io
ti stavo
cercando
Oh che bello abbiamo completato la
storia
Aspetta ma che ci succede Mi Formicola
tutto Sento un
brivido ci siamo trasformati Grazie
Vitale ci ha aiutato a salvare la storia
ora salva la tua fai la prossima fiaba
Gra fortuna Grazie grazie Spero di
incontrare
V gli auguriamo buona fortuna al nostro
nuovo amico speriamo che stia
bene Wow Ma dove sono Sono in un nuovo
cartone Wow ce l'ho fatta ha funzionato
Ehi ma che buon profumo ma Ehi Anita sei
tu che cosa stai preparando di
[Musica]
buono che paura Ma tu non sei
Anita Che strano Chi era quello Pensavo
di aver eliminato gli orchi tanti anni
[Musica]
fa Ciao ascolta conosco tu non mi
conosci Hai per caso visto la mia
fidanzata Anita Anita io non conosco
nessuna Anita soltanto la principessa
Aurora che lì che russa come un
treno russa come un treno Ma allora è
Anita è proprio lei Anita è la tua
fidanzata sì è proprio lei allora sei tu
e suo vero amore devi baciarla per
salvarla Ok la
bacerò
[Musica]
Uffa perché mi hai svegliato stavo
dormendo così
bene svegliato Sì ha funzionato Anita
sono
io cosa avete
fatto Avete rotto la mia maledizione non
lo sapete voi Che cosa significa
mettersi contro Malefica eh non lo
sapete c'è solo una soluzione
quale il libro presto
1 2 e tre abbiamo le tre copie del libro
abbiamo salvato le tre storie abbiamo
vinto
[Musica]
sì
P